[Music]
good morning england cricketers have
lost the ashes after a humiliating
defeat in the third test in melbourne
australia won by an innings and 14 runs
wrapping up the victory before lunch on
the third day making this the shortest
test match completed in australia since
1950 the hosts lead the series three nil
and will now fancy their chances of
completing a series whitewash let's
bring in our sports presenter ellen
naropa and hello to you it was
interesting wasn't it in the last hour
we were speaking to a journalist who's
out there she's an international cricket
player herself she said it's very
curious
yeah i enjoyed her analysis actually
interesting she was off for a drink he
said i think many people if you've been
up all night
you might not want to
keep listening now not a good morning
for qriket fans although to be expected
at this point wasn't it the face of
england captain joe root says it all
australia have retained the ashes after
england were embarrassingly beaten in
the third test by an innings and 14 runs
the defeat means australia take an
unassailable three-nil lead in the
five-match series
well in other news this morning a
doctor's group says it is deeply
concerned by the number of covert
patients being admitted to hospital
after the government said there'd be no
new restrictions in england before the
new year the doctors association claims
current restrictions are not sufficient
after the health secretary sajid javid
gave new year's eve celebrations the
green light but urged people to remain
cautious here's our political
correspondent joe pike
the kingdom may be united but its
leaders are divided as the four nations
diverge on their covered response there
will be no further measures uh before
the new year we won't be taking any
further measures of course people should
remain cautious as we approach new year
celebrations and you know take a lateral
flow test that makes sense celebrate
outside if you can have some ventilation
indoors if you can please remain
cautious and when we get into the new
year of course we will see then whether
we do need to take any further measures
but nothing more until then at least
boosters are part of the reason boris
johnson has held his nerve
covert cases in england may have reached
a record high but hospitalizations have
not although they are on the rise we're
just not seeing those numbers at this
point that we saw in january 2021 but
the view is very clear it's still too
early to tell about whether we are going
to see larger numbers of older people
coming in needing that kind of care as
omicron reaches the older population and
in particular as all of this
intergenerational mixing that we've been
doing over the last few days works
through
hospitality venues face restrictions in
scotland wales and northern ireland
including the closure of nightclubs but
they will remain open including on new
year's eve in england
for many businesses that is a relief we
were expecting restrictions because the
way the government is being you know on
tv and kind of scaring everybody and
stuff and and the way they were talking
about omicron is going to affect in
london we were we were expecting and
yet suddenly we saw that there's no
restrictions
all this has been welcomed by
conservative mps who were rebelling just
a fortnight ago this is excellent news
for the country it's excellent news for
the hospitality industry that people can
go out and enjoy new year
and also the underlying message is that
the data that the prime minister and the
health secretary receiving from the
scientists supports what we suspected
that omicron variant is
mild for the vast majority of cases it's
leading to fewer hospitalizations
far less serious
illness and fewer deaths boris johnson
has been criticized throughout this
pandemic for moving too slowly this time
however his pace may have been perfect
but it is a big gamble for a man who has
taken a lot of bold chances throughout
his political career and we will know
within days whether this call was right
and responsible
or reckless
for now a decision has been deferred but
with the numbers still high it has not
disappeared joe pike sky news
westminster
well more now on the response from
doctors and the doctors association says
if the current situation is left to
continue there could be severe
consequences for patients in nhs staff
in a statement it said frontline staff
are deeply concerned at the nhs being
overwhelmed by the sheer number of
patients requiring ward and critical
care beds along with the rising rates of
staff sickness way above what has been
seen before during this pandemic despite
the vaccine booster rollout program dauk
believed that current restrictions are
not sufficient and are very concerned
that if the current situation is simply
left to continue there could be severe
consequences for both patients and nhs
staff
and we are going to be speaking to dr
david nicholl of the doctors association
later 7 30 this morning so about 20
minutes
let's get an update from across the
continent now and take a look at the
situation with covert around europe in
germany protests have been held in
multiple towns and cities against new
restrictions
which come into force nationwide today
new rules include limiting private
gatherings to a maximum of 10 people
while spectators are banned from large
sporting and cultural events nightclubs
will have to close
in france after recording over a hundred
thousand cases daily the government has
announced restrictions will start after
new year big events will be limited to 2
000 people indoors and 5 000 outdoors
and working from home will be mandatory
at least three days a week for those who
can
and for the time since the start the
first time excuse me since the start of
the pandemic spain's coronavirus
infection rate has exceeded 1 000 cases
per 100 000 people spain's vaccination
rate is above 80 percent so restrictions
are low but there is concern that
immunity
might be falling
more than 8 000 flights have been
grounded since christmas eve many
because the crews came down with covid
so what state is the travel industry
currently in and can we be certain when
we're booking foreign travel that our
money is safe from more covert
cancellations well joining me now is
ryan howson founder and chief executive
of the station travel insurance group
good morning to you thanks a lot for
joining us it's extraordinary isn't it
that we're at this stage now where
before it was because of the pandemic
border restrictions but now it just they
may not be able to crew a flight
yeah yeah i mean that's true so
obviously it's very important that uh
customers have some type of protection
uh in place so that they're you know
they're covered for for their expenses
so how do you go about doing that
well i mean obviously you know we're the
market leader in the uk for for travel
insurance so i think it's important that
you go to you know a company that's been
around that's got uh plenty of
infrastructure to be able to deal with
the problems that we've got but what you
know what we have is that as part of our
insurance policy as standard without any
extra costs that you've got kobe cover
included
the the insurance industry has really
adapted
quite well hasn't it because the
beginning of the pandemic you simply
couldn't get insurance if you were
traveling if you could travel um that
would cover cobit but now it's sort of
in the package isn't it
well actually that's that's not quite
accurate because very early on
uh you know being a leader we managed to
negotiate with the underwriters to make
sure that
customers were covered pretty much from
the start of the pandemic and we led
that and we led it in two ways one
including
uh kovic cover as part of the policy but
secondly having something called an scdo
add-on because if you remember in the
early days you know the uh
well even now you've got redless
countries and what we were doing is
allowing customers to travel against uh
government advice just in europe and
that that was something that really
helped people that desperately wanted to
travel within europe so you know we led
the market but you have found that other
companies have sort of caught up and the
vast majority of uh policies will now
include some type of kobe cover but
it's incredibly important that you know
customers do check that and make sure
that they are covered for covid um no no
we don't have any redless countries at
the moment but when you're looking at
the insurance that you want to buy i
mean a lot of people will go to these
comparison websites and it is quite
difficult or it does take a lot of time
you have to do a lot of due diligence
don't you to to look at the fine print
so what are the key things that you
should be looking out for
well i mean first of all you know
without knocking the
the
comparison uh companies a lot of the big
big companies aren't actually on there
so i i think it's you know there's a
move at the moment with with uh
consumers going direct to larger
companies
like ourselves you know what you want to
make sure is that the you know that
they're covered for uh you know if
there's a delay with the with the flight
if you've caught covered within 14 days
for example with our policy that you
know you you can get your money back so
it's
it's those types of things i think that
cancellation is perhaps one of the key
things to to be covered for uh and you
know we've noticed that a lot of people
are doing
very close to the date single trips uh
but you know i would suggest that
depending upon how many times you want
to travel
that an annual multi-trip for the year
is probably the best way forward but i
would be going for a comprehensive
policy that gives an awful lot of
benefits to the consumer
that's interesting that you'd say an
annual cover because surely in the
situation that we're in now things
change so quickly do you think that it
is still better to do that or as you say
comprehensive include everything in
there yeah well the reason i say uh go
for an annual military as opposed to a
single trip
is that you know with when you take out
the policy a large proportion of the
cost of the policy
is
goes towards cancellation
and so when a consumer wants to change
we'll allow the consumer to change their
date free of charge but they will have
eaten into uh some of the policy costs
with with that whereas with an annual
multi-trip use it's you know you're
covered for the year so you know you can
can take a single trip and then
even though you've got a free date
change you've got costs on top that you
would have to cover for the cancellation
that you've already uh had as part of
the policy uh and obviously none others
really know what's going to happen and
you know when you consider that you know
you can get an annual multi-trip for
35-40 pounds as a starting point it
really is worth investing that i mean
it's less than
the cost of a pcr test
yeah yeah extraordinary isn't it how
much it is now just to travel um ryan
thank you so much thank you so much for
talking to us have a good day yeah you
too thank you thanks
an investigation has been launched in
los angeles after a 14 year old girl was
shot and killed when police opened fire
in a department store valentino or
reyana peralta who was shopping for
clothes for her quinceanera coming of
age ceremony was hit by a stray bullet
while hiding in a changing room as
officers fired at a suspect a civil
rights group has described the police's
actions as indefensible a warning this
report from charlotte lomas shows the
moments before and after the shooting
[Applause]
this body cam footage released by los
angeles police shows officers responding
to reports of an assault at a clothing
store on the 23rd of december the
officers are clearly on edge
[Applause]
at the scene they find a woman on the
floor bleeding but alive
the 24 year old suspect daniel elena
lopez is at the end of the aisle the
officers opened fire
three shots are fired with devastating
consequences
lopez is fatally wounded but one of the
bullets passes through into the changing
room and hits a 14 year old girl an
innocent victim who was in the cubicle
with her mother she was pronounced dead
at the scene
mourners left tributes for the young
girl while the chief of police in los
angeles described the incident as
devastating and traumatic but the force
has questions to answer
lapd officers have shot 38 people 18 of
them fatally in 2021 a big increase from
the seven killed in 2020. the league of
united latin american citizens america's
largest latino civil rights organization
has called for change saying this
incident is only the latest in a rash of
recent lapd shootings involving latinos
it's apparent that the days of shoot
first asked question second are rearing
their ugly head again in one of the
nation's law enforcement agencies
the california department of justice is
investigating the shooting the suspect
it turns out did not have a gun and an
innocent young girl has died another
unhappy chapter in america's history of
gun violence charlotte lomas sky news
well in other news this morning
authorities in colorado say four people
have died in a series of shootings in
denver three others including a police
officer were injured before the lone
suspect was shot and killed by police
a new report says the children's social
care system is not fit for purpose and
is handing some children over to
criminal gangs the commission on young
lives found the system can put
youngsters at risk of greater harm
rather than safeguarding them it
describes the care system for vulnerable
teenagers as infuriatingly inadequate
and for the first time in centuries the
mummified body of the egyptian pharaoh
aminotepe the first has been seen after
being digitally unwrapped with high-tech
scanners researchers have previously
been been unwilling to uncover the
ancient ruler's body
because it's decorated
wrapping with flower garlands and
because of its lifelike face mask inset
with colourful stones we're going to be
talking to one of the
professors who was instrumental in that
unwrapping so it's really interesting i
think is in 9 30 around then
it is 9 30.
now the race is on to plant trees
countries have targets companies promise
to plant millions individuals take off
with seeds and shovels but in scotland
there's concern that many of the trees
being planted are doing more harm than
good for the environment because they're
suffocating ancient woodland james
matthews reports
what trees should we plant where
it's a heated debate
they just shouldn't be here in scotland
we need
other types of forest
the key thing is right tree's right
place
trees capture carbon no doubt the light
and shade of the discussion is over the
type of tree that gets planted
those grown to be cut down for timber
tend to be non-native species
environmental campaigners say that too
often they crowd out ancient native
woodland
the problem is here this is a scottish
tree it's been growing happily here for
decades but take a look here these are
saplings from commercially planted trees
they're growing here on this slope
because seeds have blown in with the
wind left alone they'll outgrow the
ancient woodland they just
destroy them basically you know they
take away all their light and all the
nutrients from the soil
some campaigners like audrey beard say
it's bad for native species and bad for
nature
it's spreading an invasive non-native
species willfully across scotland it is
totally irresponsible
these images show green commercial
species colonizing or growing out of oak
trees
campaigners say pictures like these from
glen branter forest in argyll and butte
are behind a petition to the scottish
government they want the legal
protection of native woodland
tree concerns branch into biodiversity
the animals insects the life of an
ancient forest it's not just a climate
crisis we're in the midst of a
biodiversity crisis too we lose all that
life we lose our life so protecting
those ancient woodlands is absolutely
paramount
scotland is the most wooded part of the
uk and the scottish government plans to
increase forest coverage by 18 000
hectares a year
it points to the need to meet climate
targets and to the economic benefit
so does the industry
we've got 25 000 people working in the
sector we're contributing a billion
pounds to the economy
we're producing a product which is
infinitely renewable you know you plant
a tree it grows you harvest it and you
replant it
and
for our future a low-carbon future in
scotland to regrow our economies after
the pandemic to support the change
that's going on in rural economies for
me forestry is an absolutely crucial
element of that
in a statement the scottish government's
forestry agency said protecting ancient
woodland is vital and there's work
ongoing to do this there is no evidence
to suggest that ancient woodlands are
being lost to non-native tree
regeneration in the way described
it is the great tree debate and it cuts
both ways james matthews sky news
edinburgh
all right time now for the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it'll be unsettled this week with more
wind and rain but it'll turn very mild
by new year before then most places will
have a mild but rather gray start with
hill fog and outbreaks of rain across
much of central britain and showers to
the south northern scotland will be
sunnier but colder with apache frost
central britain will see the early rain
largely clearing through the morning
although showery outbreaks will linger
in places spreading to northeast
scotland it'll stay rather dull for many
there with fog persisting over the hills
most other places will be fine but the
south can expect some blustery showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the doctors association says if the
current covid situation is left to
continue in the uk with no new
restrictions there could be severe
consequences for patients and nhs staff
it comes after the government said no
new measures would be announced for
england before the new year
let's speak to dr david nicholl from the
doctors association he joins us this
morning thanks a lot for talking to us
this morning um severe consequences what
are those do you think
well our biggest worry at the moment is
that is actually staffing and we're
seeing that in terms of increased staff
sickness rates and there's simple
measures which could be done in fact
we've written to the uk health uh
security agency uh an open letter asking
for an upgrade in their outdated ppe
to provide fp3 masks which are better
protection
than it's currently available the kind
of standard surgical mask you're seeing
on camera there
wouldn't be acceptable on a german bus
you'd use an fb2 mask
and you know given those staff sickness
rates we are worried as as we go into
the new year um how we're going to
manage and that is you know causing a
lot of stress amongst staff in all
groups not just doctors but nursing
staff as well
okay let's break this down so staff
sickness this is
staff in the hospitals who are actually
getting covet
uh
for covered and non-committed related
reasons and that's certainly the k you
know case at the moment in london which
is very much the epicenter
of of the omicron
uh situation at the moment and in fact
overnight i just had an email from a
colleague of mine um you were mentioning
earlier about the problems
in terms of uh pilots uh and less
flights okay got staff trying to fly
back um you know who who won't be at
work next week basically because their
flights have been delayed so it's
affecting every single piece of the
puzzle yeah do you have any figures on
how many um members of staff are
isolating i'm assuming that's assuming
that's what they're doing if they've got
cover 19 or
they can't come to work if they're ill
with something else do you have any
figures of how many staff can't come to
work uh i can't give that figure off the
top of my head from my own trust for
example but uh you know it we're
definitely seeing that within uh london
and elsewhere basically and uh you know
we were already seeing that within
birmingham where i work basically um so
you know it it is it is a big issue and
we know also
in terms of itu staff uh our staffing
levels are not the same as they were um
a year ago um and that you know when we
talk about bed numbers and things it's
actually you need to understand the
staff numbers as much as anything
actually
what staff sorry was that i didn't catch
that in terms of critical care staff
so now if you look at the staffing
levels and the issues surrounding
staffing levels that you have at the
moment and you compare them to say
january this year how do they compare
uh when i speak to my colleagues in
critical care they all tell me they've
got less nursing stuff than they had 12
months ago
and when you look at the data that boss
johnson was presented with around
the omicron variant this wasn't included
was it the staff shortages
uh no but i mean i think
i mean i think it's interesting
each of the different parts of the uk
are
doing things differently and presumably
they're looking at exactly the same data
steps
i think that speaks volumes
right so okay so let's look at what he
was presented with case rates
hospitalizations how sick people are how
long they are staying in hospital um
with omicron do you think if there were
new restrictions in england it would
have an effect on the staff shortages
that you're seeing
well
we are where we are you know these are
decisions which should have been made a
couple of weeks ago and
you know i suppose what we in the
doctor's association are worried about
our members right now there's many
things we don't know about omicron okay
but there's things we do know and we
knew it's more transmissible so it
logically makes sense to update
the pp guidance because we know who you
know covert is airborne
and to provide better protections for
staff to reduce safe sickness rates it's
that simple
okay dr david nicholl we're going to
leave it there but thank you for talking
to us
thank you
well also this morning new figures show
a record number of cases of asylum fraud
by adults pretending to be children
migration watch uk says more than
hundred people aged 18 or over claimed
to be children in the year to september
i'm joined now by the chairman of
migration watch uk al mehmet thanks a
lot for talking to us good morning to
you so just explain to us how this works
wow how does it work indeed
the uh
traffickers have very quickly worked out
and if you claim to be
uh an unaccompanied minor and claim
asylum you're more likely to get it
numbers have been going up as we know uh
the channel has seen over 28 000
people crossing the channel illegally in
dinghies this year alone that's risen
from something like 8 000
our concern and my concern in particular
is that we potentially have
adults frankly they are well over 18 a
lot of them and when they are initially
assessed
if it's disputed
that they are adults the immigration
officials say
uh these people are much older than that
then their
case goes further on to be considered
later but pending that further
assessment
they are potentially going to be placed
among young people vulnerable young
people in
housing sometimes in in schools this is
quite clearly
dangerous
and it's something that we should very
quickly address
you said numbers have been going up
numbers of what exactly
the number of people claiming to be
uh children when in fact they're adults
in the past
in the year to september
uh
this year
something like
well 3 000 applications for um
child minor asylum
but
of those that have been resolved
something like 66 percent and that's
over a hundred 101
118
people have been found to be adults that
is clearly not on
but it's also the case that surely if
someone is a child you don't want to
immediately assume they are an adult so
there must be some sort of a process of
course not and there isn't any immediate
assessment and that's the whole point
that where they there is
evidence because of their appearance
their demeanor that they are
considerably older than 18
and at the moment it's
a matter of them being around 25 not
just simply over 18. if they are
obviously older than that then it's
taken further and there is further
investigation if you like to assess
their age
bearing in mind that
just about all of them will have
destroyed their documents
and
there is no way really beyond talking to
them and trying to
assess what their age really is
that um
you just cannot be absolutely certain
and we know this that it's risky it's
dangerous the parsons green brother in
2015 came in illegally in this way
and he claimed he was only 16. the judge
at his case
in 2018 said he was certain that he'd
lied about his age to get into this
country and to stay here that
is really where we're at and that is why
we're concerned
not all asylum seekers who come into
this country are
terrorists or of course not of course
we're not saying that what we're saying
is that there is significant number
where they are clearly adults
and they're being treated as children
and being placed among children that is
where the danger lies okay mr med thanks
a lot for talking to us this morning
thank you
hello again you're watching sky news
breakfast we're going to look at the
papers now and with us this morning to
review them the broadcaster and author
gemma forte and the political editor for
the sunday mirror nigel nelson hello
again to you both thanks a lot for
hanging around um the telegraph front
page
nigel this does not sound good energy
bills could treble i don't know how
anyone anyone is going to be able to pay
these
no that's the problem really and what
we've got is a
a cost of living crisis coming down the
tracks next year so not only we've got
energy bills going up we've also got
shop prices going up a new national
insurance tax to uh pay for social care
and of course pensioners will be losing
their triple lock and now we're looking
at energy bills uh doubling and possibly
according to the industry even trebling
so i mean that's going to make the the
annual average price around sort of 3
000 pounds a year
already we're paying three three pounds
75 uh a week extra
on the basis of the energy cap um being
lifted
um and that cost a hundred million
pounds just between christmas and new
year
so what the industry's asking for is is
a 20 billion pound loan to try and keep
prices down
and i think that although
uh chancellor richie soon that won't
want to start giving out even more money
i'm not sure he's gonna have much choice
gemma what do you think i mean can can
anyone afford 2022
no i mean the cost of living is going up
in so many other areas as well and i
know that already uh people who have
very very
low incomes are are really concerned
about this and trying already to not use
the heating as much so yeah it's
terrible i know quasi quatting has been
in in sort of meetings but there has to
be a real sense of urgency about this um
it's i mean it's because of the
wholesale price of gas but
it's it's staggering and it also
highlights again how reliant we are on
gas so
lots of wider um issues to look at going
forward
let's let's look at the government and
this poll on page four of the guardian
what it's found that boris johnson is
quote a significant drag on tory
fortunes
gemma that's right um
a man who had such immense popularity
won that 80-seat majority but it seems
like the emperor now
does look naked um the recent sleaze the
scandals the the wallpaper party gate
owen patterson it's taken its toll it's
bruised him and the entire party and i
think people really see him as pretty
toxic if these polls are anything to go
by um so the pulses have been out
admittedly there's not going to be an
election for a while and in this
political landscape anything could
happen and change so you know
it doesn't mean anything until until an
election happens of course but looking
at this they asked um people
if x was the leader of the conservative
party how would they fare assuming that
kierstarma is the leader of the
opposition and they looked at soonac
they looked at gove and they looked at
trust and in fact boris johnson would
lose 60 seats according to these polls
um so not good at all the one who fared
slightly better was sunak but still it
had uh starmer leading um trust
interestingly enough so she's the one
who's really really popular amongst the
conservative members but no not amongst
the wider voting public and gov
didn't do very well at all so um yeah i
think there's going to be a lot of
tourists sending a few chills through
them and having a look but then who's
going to want to take over the mantle
next year as well when this cost of
living crisis is going to take full
effect as well
nigel what do you think let's have a
look at the um that paper again the
picture of rishi sonic behind brush
johnson who do you think could be a real
contender to the leadership well i mean
certainly the ones that gemma has
mentioned that all throw their hats into
the ring
uh and i do think boris johnson could
well uh go by by springtime if tory mps
get their way
um but i mean you also kind of got to
think of that that um other contenders
are out there jeremy hunt the former
health secretary
has not given up his leadership hopes
yet so he may well throw his hat into
the ring too
rishi sunak is not terribly popular
amongst uh tory mps he's not very
clubbable
so i'm not quite sure he whether he
would have support uh this trust
obviously is going for it in a big way
but the first thing they're gonna do
before we even get to that point
is get rid of boris johnson and that's
the tricky part you need 54 mps uh to
put in to put in letters for a vote of
no confidence
and then that vote has to be carried by
more than half of them
the danger is they get the timing wrong
because if you uh go for a no-confidence
vote and you and boris johnson wins it
he can't be challenged for another year
okay spring you say nigel we shall see
we shall see
let's look at um the page two of the
mirror why has the terror threat been
made worse by lockdown
well it's mostly because according to
damian hines the security minister
you've had an awful lot of um people
stuck in their bedrooms on their
computers
and
uh and some of those only a small
proportion will end up being radicalized
because of it
we know that that um uh most paris
paris or islamist terrorists uh are
radicalized online
and so with lockdowns that they they
have more access to that and more time
time to sit on their computers now mi5
keeps tabs and about 3 000 people who
are thought to be at risk that's the
most they can actually monitor
and yet they also know that there are at
least 10 times that number
who are a danger
so after um covert is over i do think
that the uh the governor's got to look
seriously
at how they can actually give give mi5
more resources to combat this and of
course essentially that means more money
so they can recruit more people
there's a lot of spending going on and
not much money around nigel 2022 is
looking great
um talking of money let's discuss the
sales the christmas sales
because um
they may have had low footfall but
online there were a lot of people
shopping online weren't there
yeah that's right and i think there's
all sorts of factors going on here um
okay so footfall was down considerably i
mean if you compare it to 2019 boxing
day it was like 60 or something so a
huge fall um however as you say online
shopping doing pretty well and booming
but i think our habits will have changed
over the last couple of years anyway i
think a lot of shoppers perhaps who
didn't embrace online shopping before
have discovered it now you know their
credit card details are in it's all
simple once you've done it the first
time
now interesting the um retail experts
say as well boxing day falling on a
sunday might have affected it apparently
traditionally sunday is the one day out
of the week when football is is lowest
generally i found that strange i don't
know what day it is right now and i'm
not sure that would have made much much
difference in in in my way of thinking
but certainly i also know that leading
up to christmas myself included i was
being particularly careful because i
wanted to get to christmas um so i think
people are very aware you know
particularly in london i mean
it's the numbers are so huge so a lot of
people might have been avoiding shopping
for those reasons as well there's so
many people out there every day oh this
person's positive this person's positive
i got out i got out just before
christmas eve so i was lucky i was lucky
but so many people weren't um
nigel you've picked this the style page
too this is an interesting one we saw
swaziland change to their name to
eswatini and turkey are now going to
change their name why though
well the reason is they would
want to change the spelling of the name
to t-u-r-k-i-y-e
which is what turkey calls it has called
itself since 1923
but the reason the reason for this is
president erdogan
doesn't like the fact that every time
you google turkey
the kind of things that come up are
christmas turkeys
or another word for failure
so what he wants to do is to try and get
us westerners to be using the new
spelling so when we do google we
actually get the country and not the
birds um so i mean i suppose the
question is if anyone else will follow
food um
the canary islands is also having an
identity crisis
we've got to go we've got to go